You are listening to radio
lab radio from W N Y s t.
E n n.
P. E. R. Go
ahead of the everyday routine. Ooh,
ever dream of a life of
romantic adventure. Yeah.
Wanda, get away from it
all. Yeah, we offer you
[inaudible].
What do you use them this way?
Escape is, I end the free
you from the ball walls up
today or a half hour of high adventure.
Okay,
so this is an old time radio show from
the 1940s late forties I forget that
called escape. It always
starts the same way. You know
we offer you state
that phrase. I love how they say,
and here's what's great about this show
and why it seems like a good way to
start this show. Our show
is it immediately after
they say that phrase? Yes.
They then present you with a scenario
from which there seems to be no escape.
What are hanging by your fingertips
on the sheer face of an ice cliff.
Like here's one suspended a thousand
feet above incident death with your
strength running out and
with no chance for escape.
There's a million of them
pretty alone. I brought a tiny gunk
on the ground off the coast of Borneo.
You were lost in the London fog.
[inaudible] you are the subject
of an experiment, actually.
Ancient aimless tear, right?
You can take your blood. Uh, no.
Great. Oh wait, one more.
One more just for kicks.
You're like trapped in the remote
valley of the Andrea Walden by rock.
Recommend a landing you
closing in on you in the band,
the blind man, the one [inaudible].
How could you not listen to that?
What is better than like a story where
the walls are closing and nonunion?
Don't know what you're gonna do. What
am I gonna do? What am I going to do?
And then suddenly, or Skype, it's
like the best story ever. That's true.
So you're ready. Okay.
This hour we offer you three bizarre
scenarios to stories of people and planets
trying yearning who, Hey,
will they make it? And if they do,
what are the escaping? Okay,
enough of that. I'm Jad, I'm Robert.
This is Radiolab and, uh, to start,
let's talk about escape artists
because why not, right? I mean,
this is an escape show.
The most famous escape artist in
history is probably Harry Houdini.
And our first story is kind of a Houdini
story. It comes from our producer pat.
Yes. It's about a guy whose
nickname is little Houdini.
Right? Yeah. I heard the story from my
friend Ben. Hello. Like months ago. Oh,
your brother Ben, your journalism
friend? My journalism friend. Yeah.
I'm a reporter with the Tampa Bay
Times in Florida, but our story begins
at the Attorney Center
penitentiary and only Tennessee.
That's where we caught up with little
Houdini. He was between escapes.
A couple of guards walked
us into this huge cafeteria,
sat us down at this little tiny
table and brought out Chris,
Chris Gay. That's his
name. Yeah. Do y'all have,
do you interview my brother
and everything? Yeah,
we talk then come over
here and, sorry. Yeah,
I guess the first thing I noticed was he
was even smaller than I expected him to
be, was going to be little,
you know, nickname. But uh,
he was a very little reading short
little guy. Maybe five. Five, yeah.
One 41 30 kids. Prison uniform
was pretty baggy on him.
He was wearing a white ball cap and a,
he's got a big smile stretched
across his face. Skyping,
I think is it's actually addicted, I
think. Addicted. Yeah. I think it is,
but I think what's addictive about
it, it's, it's, it's a way to, uh,
it's a way to punchy. I'm gonna
stomach say, Hey, this can be done.
I can do this. I might not have been the,
y'all might have told me I can't
do no, no. My life more people.
And I've told me that
now I know I can do it.
How many times have you escaped?
Probably about 13. 13, 1313 out of jail.
Yeah. And unfortunate
to Arthur k made all 13.
I did a little research to see how that
compares to other Houdini's and there
are a few people who come close
as far as I was able to find out.
Nobody alive has that many escapes.
Could we say pretty safely that
he's the greatest jailbreaker alive.
I'll go ahead and call him that. Yeah.
So I got away from a Amanda
pretty much without even asking.
Chris began the list of the scape. He
has escaped every way you can imagine.
Slip my hand, clip off and
know what the dire dose,
what out the band in between the
[inaudible] jumped the fence,
poured all my clothes, upset my
boxer shorts like handcuffs. He said,
picking a handcuff keys,
one of the easiest things
he's ever done. Sure enough,
he's used everything from a
pen spring to a safety pin.
Even once a zipper thing might hang
KP out. My zipper scrambled out.
Windows ran out doors, climbed over
walls under walls, drilled through them.
State suicide twice. He's tricked the
cops by drawing up fake escape plans,
food their dogs by covering
his clothes and pepper. Pepper.
Another time he didn't have any pepper,
but he had found some roadkill. Stoke.
They did smell like a skunk. He rubs
it all of his body to a racist scent.
Pretty good at hiding too.
He's hitting the trees,
jumped down a trap door that
he cut the floor, his trailer.
Once he hit in a grave, I'll, I was
a shallow grave beside a dead body.
Another time.
He ended up in a college campus someplace
outside Atlanta and he hit out on top
of an air duct for two days
until the coast is clear.
But one of the interesting things about
Chris is that even though he's been
doing this for 20 years, there's never
a record of him assaulting anyone. No,
I'll refuse to do it. Stole things.
Pretty much only things to help him run.
I always refused to go in
somebodies house hours,
refused to go in somebody's garage.
She says you got rules
from self about how he
breaks the law. Almost
like a coat. In fact,
the story that got Ben Interested in
Chris in the first place is kind of the
perfect example of this.
This was a few years ago in 2007 and
got a press release from the Florida
highway patrol. Be on the
lookout for, you know,
Chris Gay according to the [inaudible]
press release. Here's what happened.
Chris had been locked up in Alabama
when he got a telephone call from his
family. He said, my mom was
a, was dying. She had cancer.
So he faked suicide,
busted out of the prison transport van
that was bringing him to the hospital,
stole a truck, and just started driving
home. Who's going to see his mom today?
His last respects and expected to live
there alone as he comes around the bend
in the road to where his mom lives.
He's driving a Walmart tractor trailer
and he's got like a dozen cops on his
tail. When I get Dan are running,
I'll run off the road crashes truck
into a field near his mom's trailer,
jumps out of the truck just as I was
running toward the house. They start,
they've jumped out of the cars and running
towards me and just before he makes
it inside, they chase him into
the woods and he disappears
without seeing his mom who
had ended up dying before,
he could see her few days later,
Chris turns up in Daytona beach driving
a tour bus that belonged to crystal
gale. They picked the
country singer. Yeah,
he's still crystal. Gail's tour bus in
Tennessee and then drove it to Florida.
Yeah. So you get this pressure right
in any think what I thought, how
do you miss with a story like this?
So Ben writes a story for
the newspaper, Big News,
and pretty soon actually tour bus that
normally carries TV news people on it
that took off and he's an escape
artist and something of a folk hero.
And soon crispy came something
of a folk song. Literally
[inaudible] Chris got caught at Grammy
Award winning bluegrass picker named Tim
O'Brien put out a song called
the ballot of Christopher Daniel.
Daniel Gay,
pretty soon of famous Hollywood
director bought the rights to the movie.
They were originally trying
to get a Johnny Depp to do it,
but they fit in the magazines again.
It's perfect. You're the
underdog making a run for it,
for what seemed to dance on them
to be really good intentions.
And part of me thought, you know, I
mean this is awesome, but it's also,
I mean there's gotta be more
to this story. Absolutely.
Who's this guy really? And
why does he keep running
for booking destination? You want
to tell us where we're going.
Going to Buckeye bottom road to talk to
tare gay is Chris, his older brother.
He says he can tell us that whole
story about how they grew up.
Here we are. Chris grew up in a small
trailer out in the middle of nowhere,
West Nashville. There
are some junk cars off in
the woods. If I entirely hanging out
with a couple buddies drinking two beers,
I'll have any certain things you want to
know about or anything or can we start
talking about what it was like when
they were kids now we lived in a little
bitty trailer down there. He
points off into the woods,
across the street on this
land. It was Chris and Tyree.
Mom and dad and a little brother named
Eddie who went by cotton and then there
was Leanne lane gay, the eldest, I
mean his older sister, cottons in jail,
so we weren't able to interview him,
but Leanne and Terry both told us that
growing up in that trailer was hard.
We grew up like mountain
paving you? No, no electricity,
no running water did their wash and the
river wasn't always much food around.
I used to be a big field of
plums, a big plant thick.
It would go down and woody,
but you can't live on plums.
And a lot of days we would be hungry.
Leanne remembers they're lying in bed.
One night night she couldn't go to sleep
because her hunger pangs were so bad
and tare said, here, this'll help ya.
And he ripped up and little dying
notebook paper gave it to Leanne. He said,
just chew it up real good and
swallow it and it'll help ya.
And for Chris and his little brother
cotton, those were the good days.
[inaudible]
because when my daddy and her separated,
mom and dad got a divorce and
the family split apart. Sorry.
Leanne went to live with mom.
Chris and his little brother Eddie,
who are 10 and 11. At that point moved
in with her dad and her dad, dad,
he really wasn't, you know, I don't
guess he just wouldn't know provider.
He wasn't around very much. I mean, he
was a
a deadbeat. Yeah. Yeah,
he, he got where he, uh,
he would get off work on Fridays and he
wouldn't come home for weeks at a time.
He'd tell him to go if they was
hungry to go steal from churches.
Sometimes they'd hike through the
woods to their grandfather's house,
their mom's Dad, who Chris says hated
him and his little brother cotton,
let me go down there and he would, he,
he got where he started making
us fight each other and we could,
if we fist out each other in the
winter, got some d, You know,
he was mean.
So that was their life beating each
other up for food. We had no kids sick.
He goes on this.
So one night one of them went and
found their dad's rifle and old 22
and a tube sock full of rusty
bullets and went out behind the barn,
uh, lit a tire fire and, uh,
made a suicide pact.
[inaudible]
cotton was going to shoot Chris in
the forehead and then shoot himself.
And Chris closed his eyes and cotton
put the gun to Chris's forehead.
Chris heard him whimper and he opened
his eyes and concept, I can't do it.
And Chris said, well, let
me, let me, let me do it.
He took the gun and he put the
barrel to his brother's head
and he couldn't pull the trigger either.
And they were 10 and 11 at this point.
10 and 11 man. And Ben says,
if you take a step back,
you can see that it's
right about here at this
point that Chris and his brothers
started to steal, like really steal.
I started that like that on bicycles.
And then they went to a little,
I guess forwarders and motorcycle
is all stuff with wheels.
Yeah.
Chris remembers going with cotton
to sit on a bluff on interstate 40.
We would go a wash,
the trucks go by and they
would dream about getting in a,
in a semi and driving far
away. Then they went to a,
I guess four wheelers,
motorcycles and cars,
and then gradually got bigger
and bigger and bigger to one day.
When Chris was 17, he stole
a a semi, didn't even really
know how to drive it, but um,
I kind of decided the keys was in it,
so I started it up and from there
there was really no looking back.
Can I pause you right
there before you continue?
Let me just name some modes of
transportation and you tell me yes or no.
What are you still in
a semi bulldozer? Yes.
Skid steer, skid steer, tractor, backhoe,
anything that's the flies. I actually
got in a helicopter once and uh,
we got in there, started flipping
switches and we finally got it.
We got the blade rotate, but it was a low,
low thing and we got scared
and got out of it. Point is,
this is his life for more than two
decades. The only things that move,
getting caught and escaping,
stealing things that move,
getting caught and escaping until
eventually he became bat guy on TV who had
police on the rod and six states.
But then one night something happened
that seemed like it might break this loop
forever. He met a girl? Yes. Yes.
Her name was missy. She was waiting
tables and a little campsite diner.
He thought she was cute and Missy, he's
a smooth talker. I'll give him that.
She liked the way he taught it
was taken right off the bat.
And a few months later I got pregnant
with my daughter and me and him moved in
together and for awhile life was really,
we still had a little money in a bank
and I was working good for a Gregory
instruction, had a good paying job,
running it up bulldozer. And uh,
I was actually going to school in
Lebanon to give him a CDO license.
We had a nice trailer and
it had a refrigerator.
Did you like it? Yeah, we ever
looked at. Matter of fact,
I was talking to my daughter last night.
It came real close with my daughters.
She remembers it like it was
yesterday. He got her a dog.
She named him blackjack first puppy. She
ever got that right there was the, uh,
it was the best moments
in days of diapers,
days I think for mine in
his life I ever worked in.
But then things got complicated.
The one day when Chris and missy
were driving in the car together,
we were going right through in the
middle of Nashville and, uh, Chris says,
look, I gotta tell you something.
I stole something cause I start a
bobcat tractor from my construction
job and to make ends meet.
As soon as she heard that missy
whipped her head around. And um,
I like hitting with a big mat
right in the middle of Nashville.
And I wanted to for a big man.
Yes I did, but it was only
funny for a little while.
A couple of days later
somebody told on me,
I got arrested and he stayed in jail
for about two years and then escaped.
I don't know how exactly
right before long,
he stole again and ended up
back in jail again. And um,
and Missy, I stayed by
his side again. She,
she was determined he'd come home
from these escapes saying, Oh,
just tell to being locked up.
He did being away from you guys didn't
want to be away from my kids and I didn't
want to be away from messy.
He's time. He got locked up.
Missy would write him letters.
I would send him money cause I work the
whole time I was pregnant with my a 13
year old. What kind of work were you
doing? I worked on the sand in line,
standard rocking chairs.
Chris meanwhile was thinking about his
next escape and when he came charging
through the front door, thinking of
roadkill, telling missy that again,
he had escaped. I stayed with him again.
But this time I started asking for
check stubs on a weekly basis and adding
hours up that he'd been gone
from time he left the house,
which I would knock down riding time there
in from you were keeping tabs on her?
Yes, I was.
She even went so far as to take $5,000
out of the bank account that they shared
by a trailer for them to live in
one that wouldn't move. You know,
I was trying try and more
or less to make him do.
Right and it seemed like it was
working. But then one night,
Chris came in after work and sat down
in the living room with missy and their
daughter to watch some TV seminar. We
heard loud beaten at the door while,
you know, I jump up and
he jumps up and um, uh,
next thing I know he was, you know,
moving that kitchen table and
sliding it out. Next thing I know,
he raises the rug up off the floor and
he jumps down in there and he says,
cover it back up. So I cover it back up,
put the table back and answer the door.
And they came in and they walked
all around the house and uh,
and they laughed. So you,
I bought this house to keep him still
and he'd cut a trap door in it. Yep.
He stayed up on his fighter the whole
time they were walking over top of him.
Wow. Yeah. I guess it was
more or less I was young,
I knowed but I was also in denial.
But eventually something happened that
kind of forced her to admit just how bad
things had gotten with
Kris day before Halloween,
Danielle and her daddy had went down to
Walmart and she had picked out a little,
which outfit, but she was old enough
and they don't, you know, she was four,
you know, trick or treating for a
four year old. That was a big thing.
The next morning it's Halloween. Her
daddy looked at her and said, what baby,
I'm going to work. Um, I'll
say this afternoon, you know,
I'll get home. Well,
get you outfit on you and we'll go
trick or treating up in Nashville.
And that afternoon,
Danielle was sitting on the back step and
then she just sitting there in a white
tee shirt and I asked her,
I said, Danielle, what are
you doing? How about no,
my daddy get home mama? He said,
we're gonna go Nashville and we're going
to go trick or treating. I said, okay,
he'll be back in a little bit. And
she sat there and she sat there
and um, he never came home that night.
You? Um, I don't really hear like,
I don't hear a lot of bitterness
from you. No. Is that accurate?
Yes. Why? What?
As far as me being upset with
Chris or hating Cruz? Yes ma'am.
Is that what you're asking me? Yes ma'am.
How could you not forgive Chris? 18 years.
That's how long I've known that boy and
I have seen firsthand where he lived,
how he lived. I'm a fighter.
I go to church, my kids go to
church. I learned to forgive people.
And Chris has had a hard
life. He needs help.
Help that I can't give him
[inaudible]
you thought for a while that you
could give him that help? Yes, it is.
[inaudible]
I should have been there for my
kids. Yeah, they take a lifetime.
I'm making this up. Yeah. You
know, I'm making up what are done
[inaudible]
so what do you make of this story, Ben?
Well, somewhere along the
way for Ben and I, this,
this story really became
about the symbol question.
Can a person like Chris, you
know, grew up the way he did?
Can a person like that change
or do you just never escape
the childhood like that?
People live with a how they grew up? Yes.
Miskiw she says if two kids and a wife
that he loves, if we can stopping.
I don't know what can, but
when we asked Chris, he said,
it's in my mind I going to change it
on our own. They're going to change.
I'm working to change. Really. Of course
he has said that before. Truthfully,
what's different this time? What?
W you know I'm doing places I don't have
to take up taking every one of them.
I'm taking her anger. I'm
taking how to be a better daddy.
I'm taking everything about if that will
knock them off for pro this month I'm
going to, I asked him can I go home a
complete another non what for? Wait,
is he saying he's going to ask
them to keep him in jail? Yeah.
The 20 years of running, he's asking
the parole board not to let him go,
which made me think, I don't know.
Maybe. And then what do you think?
I don't think there's any way
that Chris changes. I
think he's, you know,
unfortunately doomed to stay
in the cycle, which sucks.
You know, I'm sort of ashamed
that I have that opinion. Why?
I mean, why do you think
you feel that way? I,
I mean my dad was pretty
similar to Chris in many ways.
Really. My father abandoned
me, uh, when I was,
when I was a young boy and, um,
and I got reacquainted with him when
I was a teenager. At that point.
He was, um, very sad alcoholic,
uh, who often made big mistakes and,
and I played high school
football and near the end of the,
of the year, my senior year,
they put out this highlight tape.
So I took that highlight tape to
his trailer in Slick Oklahoma.
And after shooting a lot of Tequila,
we sat down on the couch together and
I put the tape in and we were watching,
you know, watching me
play football. And, um,
not long into it. My Dad
starts sobbing, just bawling,
tears running down his face. And I
look over at him and, uh, and he says,
I wish I could have been there and
I wanted nothing more in that
moment and today than to ask him,
why weren't you? And, um,
I think in some way
I get that opportunity in this
job to ask my dad that question.
Ben Says, his dad never
answered that question.
And after that day where they watched
that football tape, nothing changed.
Ben got Older, he graduated from
college, got married, had kids,
and his dad never showed up
for any of it. So he says,
when he's talking to a guy like Chris,
in some ways, I, I, you know,
I'm sitting across the
table from my own father,
which doesn't give him a lot of hope.
The only ounce of encouragement
that I have, honestly,
is if we find out that,
that Chris has indeed a,
when given the chance to get
out of jail, said, no thank you.
Maybe that gives me an ounce of hope.
And a couple of weeks ago,
Ben got a letter from Chris.
Can you just, uh, can you read it for me?
Yeah. Uh,
he says, dear Mr. Montgomery,
thank you for your letter.
I'm doing well.
I went up for parole and yes, I did ask
them to let me go through the program.
The final decision was to parole
me upon completion of the program.
I would complete it on October 4th, 2012
so he's staying well, I
better get this in the mail.
Thank again for writing. I
hope to hear from you again.
Your friend Christopher Daniel Gay.
Hmm.
Okay.
Thanks to her
producer Pat Walters into Ben Montgomery.
His story on Christopher Daniel
Gay is in the Tampa Bay Times,
which you can find online and we've
got a link to it from our website,
radiolab.org
[inaudible]. We will return to
escape in just a moment, but first,
hi there. This is Ben Montgomery.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
National Science Foundation and the Alfred
p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab
is supported by Squarespace.
The simplest way to create
a website this new year.
Make your next move with Squarespace,
whether that's starting a business
or launching a passion project,
no matter what your goals are.
Squarespace's award winning templates
can help you present your ideas to the
world.
Beautifully use offer code Radiolab
for 10% off your first purchase of a
Squarespace domain or website,
squarespace.com make your next move.
Make your next website. Hello.
This is Tom leads from Oaklawn,
Illinois Radio Lab. And need your help.
Please visit WWE NYC dot
podcasting survey.com and
tell them a little bit about
yourself and the podcasts you love in
a five minute anonymous survey. I did.
You can find the link on the show
page for this episode Radio Lab.
Really appreciate your help.
Knowing more about you helps them
make more of the shows that you enjoy.
Thank you very much.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich, Radiolab and today
we offer you as, hey
talking about escape stories about people
being trapped and then getting out and
getting free. And in our last
segment we met a guy, uh,
for whom will the escape
itself became a trap.
But now we're going to take our escape
Motif to a much bigger scale. Yeah.
And we're calling this, by the way,
the outer limit because in this one we're
going to the outer limits of the human
imagination began for us when we spoke
with this writer. Yes, I hear you.
And Dolnick is his name. And
he told us a story about,
so this is Isaac Newton's
story for the most part.
And it's a story that involves the
Earth, the heavens, God, humanity.
And you might as well throw in the
apple. Um,
the one thing everybody knows about Newton
is that an apple fell from a tree and
bonked him on the head, which
isn't true. I was told, right.
That isn't an apocryphal.
It's probably not true, but,
but it's a story that Newton himself
told. Oh, really? Because Newton,
according to Ed all his life had this
notion that he was different from other
people. Uh, not only different from, but
better. Uh, he had a pipeline to God.
God was whispering secrets, the
secrets of creation into his ear. Uh,
no one else had been blessed in this way.
Other people's role in life was
simply to, uh, to bog him down.
Not what I would call the most
modest guy now, but at any rate,
what our story begins around
1665, Newton is at Cambridge.
He's a student in Cambridge,
is hit by the plague.
They send everybody home because although
nobody understands how the disease
works, they know that, uh, if people
are crowded together, they tend to, uh,
to all get it. So, so everybody
go your separate ways.
This was a kind of an enforced
summer vacation, right?
And He's like 19 or 20 at
this point in 21, 22, okay.
Newton goes home to his
mother's farm. Mom's like, cool,
now you can help me on the farm. But
he says, no, because he has a plan.
He'd brought some books home,
a bunch of of textbooks and he locks
himself in his room and sets himself not
only to having mastered all the
science that had ever been done,
but two plunging on ahead
of everyone else on his own,
motivated by this religious faith that
everything in the universe was set up by
a god who wanted someone to crack the
code. Newton believes he's the one in.
Was He doing in his room?
I mean was he that that just sitting
there and like with a thousand giant
textbooks, all that's
known is that he did this.
He just went into his room and
came out with what we're about.
He came out with with the how gravity
works, how light works, how rainbows work,
how the tides work, and then having
done all summer, he did all this.
What did you do on your summer vacation
jet. I know Mike, my summer I am,
I learned how to fold sheets like Marines,
which I thought was pretty good too.
So after having that, I mean
one flash of insight after another.
Newton now sets his mind to one
of the great problems of all time,
which for our purposes we will
call the problem of the moon.
And just to set this up,
what everybody before Newton and
Galileo thought is there are a bunch of
ordinary things here on earth like rocks
and they behave in the ordinary way
that we know, you know,
pick up a rock, let go,
it falls and there are a bunch of much
more different mysterious, elegant,
perfect things in the sky like
the moon, which doesn't fall,
it just flutes there.
So one could conclude that the moon
has its own separate set of laws.
There are one set of laws that work here
on earth and another set that work in
the heavens and there's no reason it
should be the same set of laws any more
than New York's laws should be the
same as Paris's laws can make sense.
Actually. Heavenly things
float earthly things fall.
But then here's where the problem begins.
Newton and a bunch people at that time had
gotten hold of this new
fangled thing called telescope.
And one of the things they saw was
that the moon wasn't this a mysterious,
a heavenly body that they
seem it was a big rock,
a regular lumpy potato wish rock
[inaudible] people were like,
Huh, but Newton being of
course Newton thought.
Now wait a second. If the
job of a rock is to fall,
and if the moon is just another rock,
why doesn't it fall down? Exactly. So
what's it doing sitting up
there night after night,
hello?
And it's at this point that Newton
sitting in his room or wherever he was,
we can imagine, makes a crazy mental leap.
He thought back to a little thought
experiment. Then Galileo had come up with,
which initially might not make much
sense the connection, but it pays off.
And here's the setup.
You've got someone standing in a big
field with a gun that he's about to shoot
him and next to that person with his
gun. Is it person holding in his hand?
A bullet.
So you've got a person holding a gun and
a person holding just a bullet side by
side and the bullet in the hand and the
bullet in the gun are exactly the same
height above the ground and
now somebody says, ready, aim,
fire eight. At the instant he
says fire the man with the gun,
shoots that bullet horizontally
and at that same instant,
the man next to him holding the bullet
in his hand opens his hand and the bullet
drops. So there's one bullet
zipping along, mn falling,
and then the other one just falls, right?
We shoot the bullet out of the horizontal
gun and we dropped the bullet from
right decks to the guy
at the same time. Yes,
both bullets will hit
the ground eventually,
but when they do they'll be far
apart. And Galileo's riddle was,
which of those bullets hits the
ground first? Well,
I mean everybody would know that the one
that would hit the ground first and the
one that you just dropped because the
other one has to go all that. This is,
this is, this is a hard drill
and the answer is what? Wait.
Why is it such a hard riddle?
Because I would think that the bullet
you drop is just going to hit first.
The guns got to go all the way. No,
those two bullets both hit the ground.
The exact same incident.
Really that's, that's
an experimental fact.
The bullet from the gun and the bullet
and things lands at the same time.
This bullet that shot horizontally,
it doesn't go like Wiley Coyote running
off a cliff. It doesn't go straight,
shoot straight, straight and then
fall. It's curving as it goes.
And the thing that causes it to curve
as it goes of course, is gravity.
It's the same gravity that is pulling
the bullet that you drop. Same gravity,
same pole, same speed.
So counterintuitively,
when you drop a bullet and
it falls for this long,
when you fire the gun, it'll
also fall for that long.
Even though ends up a mile away.
See, that was Galloway was riddle and
that's as far as Galileo took it. Yeah.
Newton looked at that and
he said something smart.
Whoa. First thing you said is,
okay, this field,
let's not pretend that this is some
perfectly flat field that goes on forever.
No, we're on the earth
and the earth is round in.
What roundness means is that the
ground curves away below horizontal.
So really what's happening is that as
the bullet is shooting across the field
and falling to the earth,
the earth at the same time is very
gradually curving away from it.
Now of course, most guns, you know,
they don't shoot the bullet very
far and at that short distance,
the field is still pretty much flat.
But here's what Newton thought.
What if you could find just the right
gun that could shoot that bullet,
not just across the field but
across like thousands of miles.
And what if as it falls,
that bullet curves down towards the earth
in just the same way as the earth is
curving away from it. In this
scenario, the bullet that we've shot,
we'll keep falling and
falling and falling,
but the earth keeps falling and falling
and falling away from the bullet.
So the bullet falls forever.
The earth curves forever.
The picture never changes.
So the bullet then does what the bullet,
he's in orbit
[inaudible]
hundreds of years before
Sputnik and other satellites.
Newton has invented the satellite.
And on top of that he said when we see
rocks like the moon that are not falling,
the reason we think they're not falling
is because we misunderstand really just
as the gun launched a bullet on earth
and it goes and never false god who was
presumably a terrifically strong pitcher
launched the moon around the earth at
just such a rate that that would
continue in its circle around us forever.
This is a perpetual dance.
The partners are bound together but they
never come close and they never break
up either. It's this endless round,
round round
from which there is no the scheme.
What this does,
what Newton did is take the
moon out of the domain of, of,
of poets and, and, and,
uh, musicians, the,
the golden or in this kind of thing and
last Sobek to the same news that we use
here on earth. In other words, what
he showed is it in a very real way,
there's no separation
between us and the heavens.
The same set of laws
does govern everything.
It's one universe and
I've explained it all.
Once you figure out the
laws of gravitation,
then you can send spacecraft to
Mars, Jupiter, Saturn, anywhere out there.
If you're a radio lab
listener from way back, you
might recognize that voice.
That's Andrew Williams.
One of the first stories we did actually
I interviewed her about working on the
famous uh, golden record.
You remember this? Sure.
So the idea at the time was to put
this record on the voyage or capsule,
send it in the space.
And on the record would be all of these
sounds that represented, you know,
us kiss a mother's first words,
your newborn baby. Come on now.
In any case,
Ann was the one who was in charge of
choosing all the sounds to put onto that
record. She and Carl Sagan work together
on that project. And here's the thing,
we stopped our story as
the rockets took off,
but obviously that was just
the beginning of the story.
And the voyager capsules right now are
about to make a kind of escape that
Newton could have only dreamed of.
Okay. So record thing. And uh, our
producer limb levy has been, sorry,
I just turned my headphones off way
too. I've been following this story.
Oh yeah, you just turn it down. Yeah.
Okay. So it can pick it up. Where we, uh,
left. Okay.
So like in the point of the mission
wasn't really to deliver this record,
it was to go out and look at all the
planets in the outer solar system.
So starting in 1977, these two
little spaceships to spacecraft,
voyager one and two went racing
away from Earth snapping pictures.
And so every time before you actually
would reach another planet, you know,
all of the voyager people would
get together, go into the imaging
room and see the pictures come
from the outer solar system.
Do you remember seeing them? I remember
as a child seeing life magazine,
you know, I was seven when
[inaudible] was launched.
So this is [inaudible] author,
professor at Boston University.
As a grown up, she became part of the
voyager team. All the pictures that,
you know, as a kid, you look at the
books and to see what, how Napkin,
look how Jupiter local,
you know, just incomplete
revelations. Saturn,
the image of Saturn technique
color like pink and like reddish,
Turquoise, color yellow. And
those rings just spectacular.
They could see active volcanoes on
one of the moons of Jupiter. Finally,
that vision of Neptune,
this blue jewel, really blue,
it's all came from voyager. We had no
idea how they look like before voyager.
Neptune was the last big cool planet
and it was the last thing they were
supposed to photograph after that, right.
The cameras were going to be
shut off till save energy.
But Carl Sagan convinced them to turn on
voyager back to earth and take a final
picture. So on Valentine's Day, 1990, uh,
one of the ships slowly rotated
so it was facing back to earth
and
it snapped a picture. One
last picture. Describe it.
So
it's mostly empty. Um,
it's, it's pretty dark.
You can see sort of streaks
of light coming from the sun
and then
you honestly wouldn't notice it
if it wasn't pointed out to you,
but down in one corner, kind
of a suspended in a sun beam.
The rays are very small. Dot Blue,
a pale blue dot that with
us in Carl sagans words,
everyone you ever knew, everyone
you ever loved, every superstar,
every corrupt politician, just everyone
in all of history, everything is.
Some total think of
the rivers isn't blind,
so that one indistinguishable group
could have momentary domination over a
fraction of that pixel.
It was one of those really
rare images every single day.
I hear from people who take that
Pale blue.so deeply to heart.
It was, it was a complete reframing
after that, they come out of a off,
but here's the thing. The
ships kept going, going,
going, going, drifting
through the darkness,
going, going, going.
Even though they weren't
taking pictures anymore,
they were using like their other senses,
little instruments that detect
like how many particles are around,
what the temperature is,
so they were hurdling through this
empty space really fast. Measuring,
sending that data back and scientists
like that off where they're listening and
waiting for what was not clear,
but they knew at some point these
capsules would get to the edge,
the edge of what? The solar system,
the solar system has an edge.
I thought it was just a big spiral. Has
an edge. It's a, it's like a bubble.
C The Sun has a wind.
Every star has a wing,
but the sun has its own wind that
blows out through the solar system.
It's very fast.
It can be between 400 to 800
kilometers per second anyway.
It blows out from the sun
past all the planets and uh,
it keeps everything else out. Oh, so it's
like one up a balloon. Yeah, exactly.
The wind gives it a shape, right?
So these little things are cruising
out towards this edge, wherever it is.
Scientists don't quite know
where it is or what it is.
The guys in the control room are like
pegging the ships. Like, Hey, what's,
what's up? What do you see? Well,
the ships are like nothing. Well,
how about now? Not much. No. Nothing.
And how long before they actually
see something. 14 years. Oh Man.
It's like driving through Kansas
but like a million times. Right.
But there comes a day end of 2004 where
they stopped listening for a little
while because the antenna,
NASA only has so many antennas and
they have to use them to listen to
everything. So for a little while
the voyager teams like, okay,
you guys over there can
use the antennas. We're
going to lunch. Yeah. I mean
it's not like anything's happen.
Nothing's happening anyway.
It's been 14 goddamn years.
[inaudible] yourself out guys. It's cool.
And they come back a few hours later,
start listening again and
it's happened. Very southern.
Everything is totally changed really.
All of a sudden, boom.
The speed of the wind dropped from
around three 80 kilometers per second
to a hundred instantly, like
just all at once intently.
And then everything out there
started to get messy. Very Tall,
much metoprolol. And
before particles are also
behaving a very different way
and the fields are very, um, we are
the fields. Am I kinetic field?
So just like the sun has a wind,
the sun has a magnetic field as well.
The field starts at the sun and then
curves out in this kind of graceful arc
through the solar system
and the how the sun rotates,
create what people call [inaudible] cart.
You know how like a skirt will
flair if you spin around real fast.
[inaudible] that's apparently kind
of what this field looks like.
But way out there, it seemed like
the skirt had started to fray,
maybe tear a little threads,
had broken off and seem to be
floating around on their own.
Not connected to anything. So
what does this all mean? I mean,
if the fields are breaking down and the
wind is dying down and you said the wind
is what actually creates the
space of the solar system.
Does this mean we're out to no,
I kind of thought that was what was
happening. But no, it's not out.
And it's not quite in,
it's in the edge of the
bubble. It's in the air. Yeah.
But it's not like, I'm not like a
little thin edge. It's a, it's a thick,
thick edge. All right.
So the edge isn't just a little
line that you cross at the place.
Yeah, and while we listened,
the two voyager ships moved through
this edge for several years.
Zen. Something very
interesting happen. Um,
is that the weaned on virgin [inaudible]
stopped like completely stopped. Yeah.
So now we're out. No, no.
I mean this is what people thought.
But the other measurements like
temperature and number of particles,
the magnetic field doesn't tell
us that we are out of the Bible.
Nature surprised us again.
So now we think there's a place
at the edge of our solar system.
Why didn't they add
Angie edge of the edge?
That's utterly still no
wind at all. A pause.
People are Connie stagnation layer.
Okay.
There is a big discussion why this layer
exist and how thick it is and by how
thick it is, she means
when will it end? Because
once we get past this, who has
anything ever crossed this,
the boundary before? No.
This will be the first manmade object
to live any star and a voyager is like
right there smelling, touching
that boundary. You know,
you only do those things first. Once
like your first kiss, your
first taste of alcohol,
your first time driving a car.
The first time you see the ocean.
Oh,
these things open up a whole new world.
First time out of the solar system.
Aw.
So when is it going to freaking happen?
It might have happened
while we were talking. Yeah.
We're thinking from now. Any moment now.
Next couple of months or three
years from now, four years from now.
It's close.
Every day opened my Google alert for
voyager and I look and see did it happen
today? If it happens before the show
goes out? I'm really pissed. Yeah.
Every day. That's the first thing
you do in the morning. Oh, alright.
Like the third thing
[inaudible] [inaudible]
all right, so quick update. In 2013, uh,
NASA announced that voyager one had
finally left the heliosphere but it turns
out it is really hard to tell for sure.
And scientists are still debating whether
it is in or whether it is out or you
can find out more about that
debate@radiolab.org thanks to producer
than Levy Morocco Fair at Boston
University and any trillion.
Hi Radiolab. This is Sally
calling from Melbourne Australia.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred Baseline Foundation enhancing
public understanding of science and
technology in the modern
world or information about
Sloan at www dot Sloan top
book.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab
is supported by Squarespace.
The simplest way to create
a website this new year,
make your next move with Squarespace.
Whether that's starting a business
or launching a passion project,
no matter what your goals are.
Squarespace's award winning templates
can help you present your ideas to the
world.
Beautifully use offer code Radiolab
for 10% off your first purchase of a
Squarespace domain or website,
squarespace.com make your next move.
Make your next website.
Hey, I'm Janet. Boom, run.
I remember [inaudible].
This is Radiolab and today we're
talking about the escape scan.
In this last story,
I have a feeling that this guy
actually does kind of make it through.
This is a true, I think
he does honest escape,
but he does it in the most
original and most unusual way here,
where the story is our producer Sean Cole.
So the story starts in the late fifties
there was this little boy in Richmond
named Joe and Aggressi a junior.
He's seven or eight years old,
and he's just sitting at home dialing
various numbers on his parents' telephone
just to see what happens. He was on
a long distance call to information,
you know, five, five, five one two
one two, one to just scenario code.
This is Phil Lapsley. I first heard
Joe's story from him and he heard it
very faintly in the background, the tone,
and you just started
whistling along with it.
All of a sudden he heard a critique
and the call went away and it turns out
that the tone in the background of the
phone and his corresponding
whistle was 2,600 hertz.
Musically it's about seventh [inaudible].
So he has perfect pitch. Yeah.
And he was weirdly smart as you'll soon
discover anyway, he thinks to
himself. That's very odd. Well,
that happened once. I wonder if
it'd happen again. Does it again?
You didn't even really know exactly
what it was at the time, but he does it.
Yeah.
Again, and again,
you didn't think it was
particularly useful for anything.
He does talk about walking past somebody
at a pay phone when he was seven or
eight years old and whistling this tone
and having the phone and the phone call,
disconnect on the person. Wow. That's
amazing. Super power. That really is.
Yeah. Which means he could
be a little walking bomb.
He could go to grand central station
where there many people sitting in phone
booths and does, he could make them
all lose their phone calls. Yeah.
And no one would know. Right. But it
was more than just a cool trick for him.
This discovery was the
beginning of a kind of escape.
What were you scared of when you
were a little, I bet something
scared me. I don't
remember how old I was, but
it's all we have left of him. In fact,
he died in 2007 but he left behind hours
and hours of recordings of his voice
phone recordings. And
as he listened to them
that was afraid, you know,
something might have like
grown out of the bed and went,
found the button on the floor and
you pretty quickly realized that the
little boy in that room who was playing
with the phone and he
was kind of desperate,
he went to this Catholic school
for the blind was his mind.
He was born blind and when he was there
in the fall of 1955,
things got pretty bad.
A lot of the nuns, uh, me and
my sister really hard, you know,
and took us only one that will abuse.
She used to have me get on the table,
then she would get up on
the table and lie down.
[inaudible] the bad touching
things were pretty bad at home too.
Daddy would slam mother and hurt her and
break things and lots of scary sounds
and stuff at night that has my
phone up close with the dial tone.
[inaudible]
I'm on the dial tone.
That was always there.
It's a nice warm tone. It never yelled
at, never fought.
What a wonderful thing of telephone in.
Well, just a nice way for
him to comfort himself
those long nights.
[inaudible]
and so how did exactly did the,
the whistling thing he was doing,
how did that help him?
It takes a few steps to explain,
but it turns out that that tone was the
key word in a hidden mechanical language
that controlled the phone system.
Hmm.
He wasn't supposed to be able
to hear it at all. In fact,
it was an internal signal probably
bleeding over from another line.
And when a long distance line was
idle, when there was no call on it,
this tone would be being
played continuously.
Basically the tone means that the line
is free and silence on the line means
there's someone trying to make a call.
So say you're in New York and you want
to call La, you pick up your phone,
the circuit's got this tone on it
and marking the circuit is idle,
dial the La number.
And at that point your line takes
away the tune for just a moment.
It goes silent. And La goes, AH,
New York wants to make a phone call and
then la drops its tone and the New York
and La machines talk to each other.
So that's one discovery.
Another discovery is that you can dial
a phone by just having the hook switch,
that little button where you hang up,
tap that three times delta number three,
seven times, dial the number seven.
And so then Jo thought we pulses tones.
Maybe if you were to make a little
bursts of a tone. So something like
Joel's demonstrated on a web
show called hacks or radio,
you were nine. If you were
to do something like that,
maybe you can actually dial a call
and you could actually make it.
That's exactly how the phone system
used to send calls back and forth.
That was its language. That's right.
Joe Learned how to speak telephone,
which was amazing. I mean,
I think that's amazing. Um,
but isn't he just dialing the phone
with his lips as opposed to using his
fingers? Yes, true.
But Joe made one more little discovery
that would change his life forever.
So yeah,
if you first dialed a a number like
long distance information, five, five,
five one, two, one, two.
The telephone company doesn't
charge for call for information.
So what he figured out was that once
you get the operator on the line,
if you then whistled to disconnect
but only for a little bit,
only for a second or two,
the line nearly disconnects,
but it doesn't all the way.
It just sits in this kind of limbo waiting
for instructions waiting to be used.
Huh. And you can
the route your call by whistling the
digits and wanted to dial and make a free
call because the phone company again
thinks that you're still connected to
information and it's not
charging you for that.
He was like having an unlimited
plane ticket to anywhere Joe
could call anywhere he wanted for free.
Come coming up and explore
the number you have.
Code is not connected to listening
and so he started calling
all over the world,
even broken number numbers just
to hear the different voices.
I'm going to be cold calling that gang.
I used to do this by
the way. Did you really?
My sister and I would get on the phone
where you could call information that was
a free service. Yeah. And
we said, hello information.
Can you please contact us with Toronto?
And then we get the Toronto operator and
let me say [inaudible] could you please
get us in comp project with Churchill
Ontario, which was way up north.
Then the Trisha lady
would come on and I'd say,
can you please put us in charge with
[inaudible] York intuit place and made
the transfer you to the northern spice.
We would be talking to a person
in the Arctic for nothing. Wow.
It was the sense of going
long distance for free.
Now imagine you're a blind kid
doing that in an abusive home.
You can't even run away. I think
the phone represented freedom.
Um, it represented a place
that was under his control.
He can be an expert in
it, you know, it was,
it was a place that he could do all
sorts of things that maybe he wasn't so
easily able to do in real life.
[inaudible]
so what happens next?
So things get a little bit
better for Joe as he gets older.
His mom takes him out
of the Catholic school.
Once she finds out that
the nuns are beating him,
he never told his parents
about the sexual abuse.
He gets more and more
savvy with the phone.
And then finally he goes off
to the University of South
Florida where he starts
showing off.
It started out,
Joe told a student that he can whistle
her for your phone call and the student
said, no you can't. And
he said, want a bet?
So they bet a dollar and Joe whistled
a long distance call for him.
And before long there were crowds of
40 kids who were falling them around
wanting to see him do
this parlor trick. And,
and then he whistled up.
This one particular fateful,
I was trying to whistle somebody in New
York, which is area code five one six
[inaudible]
but instead had wound up in
Canada, which is five one four
okay.
You can see if you're whistling calls,
you could easily get
off by one or two beeps.
So he wound up talking
to an operator in Canada.
And the operator in Canada put
his call through to New York, uh,
but then actually managed to listen to
the call and then the student was talking
about the,
the wizkid who put the call through to
him for him and telephone companies.
Security ended up tracing it back
to a University of South Florida.
It was just a gossipy operator
who told on him. Well,
gossipy or security conscious depending
on how you view it. Fun Ruining.
That's how I view.
So Joe Busted and he nearly gets kicked
out of school and the whole thing causes
just enough of a stir
that people find out.
The local school newspaper wrote an
article about it and it got picked up by a
wire service.
Next thing you know there are newspaper
articles and publicity and yeah,
here's the weird thing. As news travels,
did you see this article about the
blind kid in Florida? You can do this.
It turns out Joe wasn't,
there were all of these
other June Brosius out there
hacking the phone system to
two one, two, three, nine,
six you know you mean
I'm not the only one.
You mean there are other people
who are interested in this as well?
They weren't whistling God, no, no.
Some of them would use these little
machines called blue boxes that would make
the tones.
A couple of kids actually modified a toy
whistle from a box of captain crunch.
And because Joe got caught, they all
started to find out about each other.
That really ended up being the focal point
for a whole generation of fun fleets.
This is NBC nightly news
phone. What phone free
phone freaks will tell you.
Phone freaking began with a blind
young man named Joe and Bresha.
One thing he discovered was that
he could whistle his own call.
Okay.
And before long people are
actually calling John Garcia
and a network starts to
form n, um, the phone
freak started finding
broken, uh, vacant member
recording. So for example,
you dial a nonworking number and you get
the usual telephone company recording.
They not working number,
but it turns out some of those were
broken in such a way that the volume level
was very low. And if multiple
people called the same number,
they could talk right now.
Teenage kids would call. Anyway.
It turned into a party line.
Kind of an annoying one because you had
this announcement that was repeating
every 30 seconds. Oh my number.
But it's still allowed teenage kids to
talk to one another at the department
I've known. Wow.
Oh, so this is it. I mean he
found his tribe basically. Yeah.
And he would call the conference lines
and talk with them about phones and
freaking and everything. But that
really wasn't what he was after.
And I think it's an
interesting thing because,
so say you're a lonely kid and you start
playing around with the phone or you
start playing around with
scrabble or whatever it is,
you get really obsessed about some thing
right through the magic of that thing.
You end up meeting other people.
You sort of have a choice
to make at that point.
Choice one is embraced the
community. Choice two is oh,
that size.
It's great that there are other
people and I get some stuff from that,
but you know, I found this thing,
my telephone, my scrabble set,
whatever it is I'm obsessed by and
I'm still obsessed by it and I,
it seems to me like he'd sort of
made the choice to go for the thing.
It's not that he didn't
like the community,
but he was still searching for something.
Esquire magazine, 1971
march of 1971 is when he moved
to Memphis quarter and that month
he had done very little long distance
phone freaking from his own phone.
He had begun to apply for a
job with the phone company.
Yeah. He went there intending to
get a job and be a man as he, yeah,
and he wanted to stay away from
anything illegal in gressier quote,
any kind of job will do anything as
menial as the most lowly operator.
That's probably all they'd
give me because I'm blind.
He wanted to be a telephone man. He
wanted to take his lunchbox to work.
He wanted to get a paycheck. He wanted
to be a real person like everybody else.
This is Steven Gip, one of Joe's best
friends. He lived in a couple of places.
The first one was, you know, just imagine
skid row. I mean it was, it was, you know,
you woke up one morning when the heat
went out and he stepped on a dead frozen
rack cause he had ended up sleeping
in his coat. I mean you know,
that's all we could afford and uh,
he can't get arrested in Memphis. Uh,
you know, he can't get
a job to save his life.
So he decides to get
arrested literally by,
um, doing this very,
very elaborate public freak where he
gets a bunch of his freaking friends on a
conference call and he starts dialing
up for an embassies like the armed
services and Moscow like and pretended
that he was calling as a radio host and
that all of his friends were his studio
audience high. This is, you know,
so and so from this radio show,
do you have time to talk and be on
the air with us today? Oh Great.
Cause he wanted to stay on the phone line
so that the phone company could trace
him. Cause he was, he says they're
not really speedy, you know,
he wanted to give them a
lot of time to catch them.
Two weeks later is when he walked out
the door and you know the FBI came up and
said Joseph and Rezia
and why did he do this?
Cause he was trying to try to get the
phone company pay attention or something.
That's right. That's right.
In the hopes that he would
get a free meal in jail or no,
in the hopes that he would get a job
with the phone company. That's right.
What a weird way to go about
it. And amazingly it worked.
Really? Yeah. I've got four
job offers, all phone jobs.
So he got a job at a little independent
Millington telephone company and they
started cleaning telephones.
Anything from cleaning phones to servicing
equipment, any kind of job will do,
but any kind of job wouldn't
do. You really didn't like it.
It's that kind of thing where you
realize your lifelong dream and then you
think, wait, I can dream anything I want.
I can dream bigger than this.
And so in 1975 and 76 whatever,
he moved to Denver, Denver,
where every dream is in reach paid for
by the committee to promote Denver.
And he started hobnobbing with all the
telephone guys and go to the public
utilities commission and that's when
he stopped working for Mountain Bell
Mountain Bell telephone and that's
when he started freaking for the man.
And so he worked as a
network troubleshooter and
at this point he had such an
intimate knowledge of all
the little clicks and pops
of the phone system that he
could tell from those noises what was
going on and we network how your call was
being routed.
There was a problem somewhere along the
line what the problem was and even where
it was. Wow. Strictly from
listening, strictly from listening.
This was listening to the
dial tone times. Nearpod
[inaudible]
no one should go through
and he demonstrated his powers on the
New York radio station. WBAI there was,
there was a show called off the hook.
Okay, good old bang.
No, just to click now.
It'll answer briefly.
That was a little funny. CML.
It'll stay like that as long as you
want to stay on it. Some nice sound.
I didn't know always dropped the ball.
Fun Number five efs. I forgot.
God. Wow. He's like a Jedi
master. Yeah, he's made it. Yeah.
And so he quit what gave
up the job for his friend.
But it sounds like you
finally got what he wanted.
I think like he became the master of
the world that he had escaped into,
but he never really dealt with the
world that he had escaped from.
Meaning like that little boy,
that broken little boy that he was still
needed a kind of fixing in a way that
wasn't going to be, you know, no job
is really going to solve that. So,
so my time,
he moves to Minneapolis on June 12th
cause six 12 was Minneapolis area code and
he basically becomes
a kid again, you know,
just everything it did from that point on.
Other than his phone
had to do with children,
he'd visit with children
who were terminally ill.
You just visit with children in general.
I've got a recording at home
affect those, listening to it.
Last night before he
came to the interview,
I was laughing and giggling because all
these little girls were coming up and
they were saying, hi
[inaudible]
when I could hear the parents in
the back saying all of this stuff,
don't sit on his toys
and a, you know, he acts,
you start talking about little
[inaudible] a little more to me, you know,
about his being abused and you
know, missing out on his childhood.
And he was at a seminar at uplifting
seminar and the instructors had something
on the order of, I'm paraphrasing,
like, tell me how you feel right now.
And he screamed and yelled and threw
up his arms and said, joy bubbles.
And in that moment he decided that
he would actually go by that name,
Joey bubbles. You may changed his name
legally changed his name to joy bubble,
all one word.
And it was around this time that he
decided and announced that he wasn't going
to be an adult anymore.
His old name and his past was gone
and he wanted to be five years old,
five years old, forever.
[inaudible]
and then he started doing this.
Gosh, this may already, well,
I'm glad to call them stories
and stuff. Your storyteller,
joy bubble here in Minneapolis, Minnesota.
You know the recordings I
mentioned at the beginning,
they're all from the show
that Joe recorded every week.
He called it stories and stuff
and instead of broadcasting it,
he'd record the episodes to an answering
service and then you'd call a number
and listen to it on the phone.
Hello, kids and Thai adults. I think
the title is part tiled and part of,
don't worry. Hello. Hi. Hello.
If the story isn't the stuff you've read,
the stories and stuff is by both here in,
that's all one word. No, don't
you dare. But at Joey a bubble,
and this may be too
armchair psychoanalytical,
but it really feels as though it's the
kind of show that he needed to hear when
he was a kid.
Like the new five-year-old was trying
to go back and say something to the
five-year-old from the early
fifties. Something akin to,
it's okay in the end
it's going to be okay.
Yeah, there is help. If you
had like an imaginary friend,
a bunch of them come that are just
looking for somebody to love and play with
and talk to. And so all you
have to do is any quiet day,
just get quiet and ask for one.
The kind of like the calm and, uh,
they'll be with you for as long as you
want up and bond the Finito for lifetime
and beyond.
[inaudible]
thanks to producer Shawn Cole and
to Stephen Gibbs and Phil Lapsley,
who is now finished a
book on freaking and run.
I remember Krulwich thanks for listening.